[Music]
on this Tuesday night the warning from
doctors don't let your guard down
climbing covet cases the sub-variants
spawning anxiety about reinfections hit
our our family twice and the rapid test
just developed in Canada new evidence of
Trump's outrageous plot to stay in power
the meeting has been called the craziest
meeting of the Trump presidency what
White House staff rushed to stop feeling
the heat the UK prepares for a potential
emergency and breathtaking images beamed
from space it's just outstanding the
universe captured by the most powerful
telescope ever created
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Tracy Tom
good evening and thank you for joining
us after two and a half long years we
recognize Canadians are fed up and while
no one wants to hear this cases of
covid-19 are again climbing and causing
strain on the Health Care System tonight
Ontario is considering expanding booster
shots to all adults and BC has already
announced it will roll out a second
booster program to people aged 12 and
over this fall the chief of the World
Health Organization says covid-19
surveillance has reduced significantly
and limited testing and genome
sequencing is clouding the true impact
of new variants
Severance of Omicron like BF4 and ba5
continue to drive waves of cases
hospitalization and Death Around the
World
cases reported to the who have risen by
30 percent in the last two weeks in BC
hospitalizations have increased 35
percent in a week and in recent Days
Seven hospitals in Ontario have either
closed or made plans to temporarily
close emergency rooms due to critical
Staffing shortages and outbreaks and if
there's one takeaway as shalima Maharaja
reports while we may be done with the
pandemic it is not done with us
what I have thought at the time was that
covid you know once you have it you're
immune you know like you shouldn't be
getting it again and that soon after I I
was really shocked a bakery owner and
singer Christine Enz knows well the
lingering symptoms of covid-19 she's had
it twice first in February then in April
and yes she is fully vaccinated even at
her booster my son just has recently
contacted it for the second time as well
um just in the last month so
um that was another surprise too because
uh he's 20. and he's very healthy and
active kid and and
so yeah it's hit our our family twice
twice
with the emergence of Omicron
sub-variants particularly ba5 fueling
the latest wave there is concern about
reinfections many of us thought that if
you had an earlier infection or a
vaccine then you would be protected
against homicron it appears that is not
as successful as we had hoped
researchers at the University of Toronto
have created a rapid test capable of
gauging just how effective neutralizing
antibodies are against the virus think
of the virus as a goalie and then our
body is trying to
um
take shots on the goalie and so if we
measure General antibodies that's
telling you more or less shots on goal
neutralizing antibodies are measuring
shots that actually score a goal as for
Christine ends I'm just starting to get
my taste and smell back she still plans
on getting her fourth dose when she can
I think that's still important um even
more so now I think I know some people
have said wow why bother with the
boosters if everybody's going to get it
anyways but it's not like the chickenpox
where you just get it and you're done
shalima Maharaj Global News
Canada's Premier is met for a second day
of talks in Victoria BC again calling on
Ottawa to boost its share of Health Care
funding from 22 percent to 35 percent to
rebuild the ailing system
federal health Minister Jeanie duclow
says Ottawa wants accountability on any
new cash given but as Richard zusman
reports BC Premier John Horgan says the
feds are fueling a problem that doesn't
exist
cough cop out I think it's a cop-out and
it's a mechanism to divert attention for
the federal government to say well we
don't want to continue to fund health
care because you might do something out
else with the money after two days of
meetings in Victoria the premiers
lashing out against the federal
government frustration the Prime
Minister nor any of his ministers bother
to show up here to hash out a health
care deal we want to sit down and
reimagine Canadian Health Care in 2022
let's get on with that that's the
message to Ottawa the sticking point as
it always is is money the provinces
insist Ottawa provides just 22 percent
of Health Care funding and is asking for
that to go up to 35 percent an estimated
increase of 28 billion dollars per year
but Ottawa says these numbers don't
factor in specific transfers and the
one-time influx of covet cash and no
deal would come without conditions on
how the money is spent what we're
talking about now is not asking the
federal government to monitor our
budgeting processes we're not saying we
don't want to be accountable for the
expenditures we make we're saying to
Ottawa the system isn't working Stuck in
the Middle millions of Canadians looking
for a family doctor waiting in an
emergency room or generally let down by
a struggling Health Care System there
are statsa suggests that because of the
primary care crisis BC is facing there
are up to four deaths a day that are
linked to Primary Care deficits the
Canadian Medical Association says they
appreciate the premier's pushing for
more money but contend all politicians
need to push past the fighting we've
been sounding the alarm about the Health
Care system for a long time it's just
right now it's at a level of Crisis I
think that we haven't seen where there's
real true risks to People's Health by
not being able to access Care One
suggestion for an immediate fix would be
a plan in terms of the human resources
needed to make the Health Care System
run smoother in each province but until
then as fighting continues and means
Canadians wait a little bit longer for
the health care they so desperately need
Richard Wilson Global News Victoria
in the United States the January 6
committee continued its public hearings
today with a focus on the role Donald
Trump played in assembling the mob that
attacked the U.S Capitol U.S lawmakers
say the former president refused to
accept election results and accused him
of setting the stage for violence then
not acting to stop it once the chaos
ensued Jackson prosco reports
in devastating detail the January 6
committee laid out Donald Trump's
refusal to accept his clear election
loss president Trump is a 76 year old
man he is not an impressionable child
the committee heard how Trump ignored
the evidence instead turning to an
unlikely team of outside advisers who
pushed out landish schemes to stay in
power like this draft executive order
this proposed order directs the
Secretary of Defense to seize voting
machines quote effective immediately
former White House counsel Pat cipolloni
testified he tried in vain to steer
Trump and his advisors away from the
conspiracy theories to the federal
government sees voting machines that's a
terrible idea that's not how we do
things in the United States yet on a
mid-December night those pushing the
schemes met with Trump in the Oval
Office when White House staff found out
they rushed to intervene at times there
were people shouting at each other
burrowing insults at each other what
they were proposing
I thought was nuts I'm going to
categorically describe it as
you guys are not Tough Enough it was
after that meeting ended that Trump sent
his Infamous tweet summoning followers
to Washington this could be Trump's Last
Stand the time for games is over the
time for Action is now in the days
leading up to the sixth messages show
Trump was quietly planning to March to
the Capitol himself and spoke with his
former advisor Steve Bannon on the
morning of January 5th soon after Bannon
said this on his podcast
all hell is going to break loose
tomorrow Court filing suggests that
ahead of the sixth extremist groups like
The Oath Keepers were making their own
plans shipping weapons and explosives to
the Washington area this could have been
the spark that started a new Civil War
perhaps the most powerful testimony came
from those who stormed the capital they
were clear-eyed that their actions came
at the direction of the man who refused
to concede the election so why'd you
decide to March to the Capitol
um well basically you know the president
you know got everybody riled up told
everybody head on down so we basically
were just follow him when he said
perhaps one of the most startling pieces
of evidence presented today were text
messages from Trump's own campaign
manager to another Trump associate in
the aftermath of the sixth the campaign
manager said quote a sitting president
asking for Civil War I feel guilty for
helping him win
Tracy and Jackson with more hearings
expected next week have we learned
anything else about potential witness
tampering in the meantime this is
something the committee has brought up
before and brought up again today and
they say a potential witness who has not
yet testified was recently contacted by
former president Trump that person
declined the phone call notified their
lawyer their lawyer notified the
committee and now the Department of
Justice is involved
all right our Jackson prosco in
Washington for us thank you Jackson
back here in Canada news from Rogers
tonight the company says it is giving
customers affected by its massive
Network outage a credit equal to five
days of service as opposed to the two
days previously offered the news comes
as the federal government is promising
big changes with the industry Minister
demanding the big telecoms put aside
competition and work together when
emergencies happen but as Abigail Beeman
reports how that would actually work is
another question
the investigation by the crtc will bring
to light what really happened the
industry Minister was so confident the
crtc would investigate the Rogers outage
Francois Philip champagne used the word
inquiry 10 times Monday the outage was
Friday it took the crtc until Tuesday to
send Rogers a letter seeking information
saying while the commission considers
the complaints and calls for a public
inquiry before it Rogers is to provide
by the 22nd of July comprehensive
answers but making no commitment to an
inquiry or investigation many frustrated
customers are clamoring for I said to
them in in no uncertain terms this was
unacceptable full stop champagne says
that was his message to Rogers in that
nearly hour-long virtual meeting where
he demanded telecoms come up with a plan
in 60 days to help each other through
outages providing emergency roaming and
better communication this is the first
time that the federal government has
actually drawn A Line in the Sand
decided to it's to tell the Telecom
industry it's time to change the way
that you do business stop focusing
exclusively on profits in statements of
their own Rogers and tell us say they're
ready to follow The Minister's lead
while Bells focuses on investing and
delivering for its customers with no
mention of the minister or working
together there's a whole host of
potential Technical and even legal
challenges as well as compensation
because
think of it this way you're giving
access to your networks if your bell or
tell us to Rogers who's a fierce
competitor of yours there are also
questions about exactly how this help
could work the minister has said Bell
and tell us were happy to help but there
wasn't anything they could do the
internet sets an important precedent for
us it was designed to function in the
events of the nuclear war when chunks of
it might have been destroyed and traffic
would still automatically find its way
to where it needed to go it may not be
easy or quick but some tech experts say
The Minister's call is certainly
technically possible Abigail Beeman
Global News
Ottawa
a somber scene in the streets of Tokyo
coming up the mourners who bid a final
farewell to former Japanese prime
minister Shinzo Abe
Japanese mourners paid their last
respects to former prime minister Shinzo
Abe at a funeral in Tokyo today days
after he was shot while speaking at a
campaign event
crowds of people lined the streets as
the Hearst carrying Abe's remains drove
through Japan's capital it paused at
places of significance to Abe including
his former office and the Parliament
building where he worked as a lawmaker
since 1993.
a private funeral for the 67 year old
was held earlier in the day
Ukraine's president slamming Canada's
decision to send an important piece of
repaired pipeline equipment back to
Europe
is
in his nightly video address Monday
Vladimir zielinski says the decision on
the Nordstrom pipeline turbine will be
seen as a manifestation of weakness by
Russia on Saturday the Canadian
government said the turbine which is key
to the operation of the pipeline that
supplies Europe with natural gas from
Russia could be returned to Germany
after undergoing repairs in Montreal
that decision caused Kiev to summon a
senior Canadian Diplomat to express
anger with the move
zielinski warned after the pipeline is
restarted Russia will have the power to
cut off the flow of its natural gas to
Europe at any time
as Russian forces make progress in the
eastern part of Ukraine attacks on
civilians are intensifying video from
Ukraine's State emergency service shows
firefighters trying to put out a burning
apartment building in mikolai
in the town of chasiviar 38 bodies have
now been recovered from the rubble of a
five-story apartment building that was
hit by Russian missiles Saturday Russia
has continually denied its forces are
targeting civilians
the Eurozone currency block is expanding
Europe's Finance ministers have signed
off on an agreement for Croatia to adopt
the currency as of January 1st Croatia
which became a member of the European
Union in 2013 will become the 20th
country to use the euro and the First
new addition to the block since
Lithuania in 2015.
caught on camera next heart-stopping
moments for some hikers
foreign
any hiker wants to see take a look at
that wave of snow and ice making its way
down the mountain above but that is
exactly what this surreal video captured
as hikers made their way through the
mountains of Kyrgyzstan last week not
long after the massive Avalanche
engulfed at least one person in a scene
that looks straight out of Hollywood
oh god
oh dear God
now incredibly all 10 members of the
group survived with only a few suffering
minor injuries the hiker who posted the
video said they had nowhere to run as
there was a cliff behind them
and as alpine glaciers are melting
rapidly extreme heat continues to hit
regions in Western Europe and the UK in
Britain an extreme heat warning is in
effect but the country's top officials
are on the verge of declaring its first
national Heat Wave emergency as the
temperature soars and people are at risk
of illness or death Redmond Shannon
reports from London
scorched Earth outside the British House
of Commons appropriate given recent
events in UK Politics the truth is the
result of a run of unusually hot and dry
days in London Town
even in normally temperate Scotland
these madagascan Rascals can hardly cool
down since records began in 1884 the
UK's 10 hottest years have all happened
in the past two decades the average
global temperature has risen 1.1 degrees
to people here admit it's no anomaly
to London quite a few times but it's the
most hot season I've ever experienced
you can't deny that the temperatures are
increasing like people our age are quite
concerned about
the rising temperatures and now the
National Weather Service here in the UK
has issued an extreme heat warning
starting Sunday it says the all-time
temperature record of 38.7 degrees could
be broken with above 40 even possible
one local Authority has its winter
gritters on standby loaded not with salt
but sand to cool older asphalt roads
never designed for heat like this
they're the ones that would be more
susceptible to this and actually you can
actually get like a delamination of the
road as well
on the roads of Spain it's even hotter
outdoor workers sweltering in the 40s in
Lisbon it's a bit too much for some
tourists we're trying to avoid the
hottest times of the day because of the
little one so we're uh come out early
today climate scientists worry that
scorching summer days like these could
soon become all too common Redmond
Shannon Global News London
a galaxy far far away next space the
final frontier in focus
foreign
following a sneak peek from the White
House NASA revealed four more highly
anticipated images from the 10 billion
James Webb Telescope today the stunning
Beauty shots reveal details never seen
before and give astronomers the deepest
and sharpest view of the universe
they've ever had to work with Mike
Armstrong was at the Canadian space
agency this morning for the long-awaited
unveiling
the launch of the web telescope on
Christmas day was where the waiting
started it still had to make a 1.5
million kilometer trip out into space
open align calibrate and then finally
start sending back images they are just
stunning astrophysicist Sarah Gallagher
works with the Canadian space agency and
last week had a sneak peek yes so I know
I had to bite my tongue all I could say
is they're going to be right okay Amber
so here it is the official unveiling
after all the waiting was made by NASA
here we go with the watch party outside
Montreal at the Canadian space agency
wow look at that today for the first
time we're seeing brand new stars that
were previously completely hidden from
our view honestly it took me a while to
even figure out what to call out in this
image there's just so much going on here
it's so beautiful this is an image of
Stefan's quintet five galaxies each
containing Millions to hundreds of
billions of stars this image is a
planetary nebula a dying star something
we've never seen like this but as
impressive as each image is it's the
data behind them that excites scientists
Webb isn't just showing what's out there
it scans space in infrared wavelengths
giving information about the distance of
what we're seeing and its composition
this image shows the water found in a
scan of a distant planet wasp 96b those
sorts of data are just Exquisite now
Canada had two major contributions to
the web telescope the find guidance
sensor that allows it to point and stay
pointed at objects and the near-infrared
imager and slitless spectrograph that
helps analyze light
it's so thrilling to actually have an
instrument that we worked on that
actually contributes the science that
that spectrum of water from a planet wow
there was some good news early in the
telescope's mission it took less fuel to
reach its destination than expected and
instead of operating for a decade it may
now last 10 to 15 years longer there are
likely future astrophysicists who will
work with the web telescope who aren't
even born yet
my carbs on global news saint-siber
Quebec
pretty incredible well that is global
national for this Tuesday night I'm
Tracy Tong tonight's your Canada is this
colorful neighborhood better known as
Jelly Bean Row in St John's Newfoundland
and Labrador we love seeing your Canada
so please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks so
much for being with us will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow good night
[Music]